okay okay
what do we got here
uh looks like we got a
an elevator and
uh um a room an elevator and some scared
scared japanese people
oh god
okay there's this guy here i have a
chill
that hair drop is the scariest part
okay uh let's look at this let's look at
this um
what's going on here
oh okay
just an average gal you know like she's
just like i hope i even use a safe
elevator today oh she's going into the
messed up elevator
all right all right let's say no problem
and she's like good luck ma'am on your
elevator experience uh thank you okay
let's see
and just looking around nice mirrors and
nice bangs all right everything's going
to go pretty well
and oh oh no the power's out i hope i'm
not left here to die
okay let's uh let's lock more quirk
around and uh
kind of scared um
uh let's say
um oh that noise
what is
that i hear some rattling and
uh lights please uh sir lights
um
well i'm scared my bangs don't provide
light or sunlight uh lights please light
nights
there are no lights i say i'm just
pressing those buttons even though they
don't work like i'm pretty scared
um let's say let's see
i'm scared hello anyone oh
um
i'm ah i'm yelling
oh uh
horror mode activated uh please someone
uh this man he's balding next to me
oh no the lights are gone oh i took on
please help sir
anyone anyone
oh
oh okay he's gone he's gone i need to
get the [ __ ] out of here i gotta get
some tampons please help me help
oh jeez oh no the lights are off the
faulty wiring faulty wiring
this is horrible oh hard wood activated
oh oh my god let's scare the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of her it just passes out great
idea
okay yeah she's scared
what's
he gonna do suck his dick like
oh no oh okay i guess we got some new
victims because we got some new victims
uh mr hipster here oh uh have a nice
experience sir uh thank you ma'am
just gotta take this elevator i don't
need your help now okay george closing
let's see let's see
um you know just i love my shorts i love
my old navy outfit like
oh
no
faulty wiring what is this
i'm not an engineer i'm just an art
student like how
how
what the [ __ ] is going on
my shirt is so tight
please sir
help
echolocation does not work here
oh i'm gonna climb oh what is that hello
sir
anyone who's there uh buttons hello
not jesus oh jesus what the heck is this
what the [ __ ] oh man
oh god man man man please open ma'am
ma'am
ma'am come back ma'am
i'm scared and i'm skinny
oh my god i got pre-cum dripping out
okay mitchum went activated
okay oh
no undershirt [ __ ] frightening
oh uh sir hello hello who are you
oh floor mod activated oh god
oh god get me out of here
man
my tuition
oh oh floor mode activated oh jesus
oh okay everything's okay
my button up is still good my collar is
still good but i'd like to get out of
here
jesus jesus
very very well done very well done okay
okay
um let's uh oh he's
oh my god
this is not good
oh [ __ ] is he raping him what the [ __ ]
please don't rape him
oh he's touching his scalp that's the
worst thing you can do to a japanese guy
just touch the scalp
he's like place there like plays like
he's a guest
why are you touching me sir how are you
touching me
my eyes they're open
oh what's this
oh
oh no
a celebrity
this is gonna be just
very unique
we're gonna see a celebrity perspective
very nice outfit okay
and hair that could kill and protect so
let's say let's see
um
oh yeah check check the tonsils good
good teeth good good i'm very handsome
oh i hope this power doesn't go out so i
can keep looking at myself oh no
i guess that happened
what to do now what to do now like
uh hello sir anyone i'm a celebrity
uh i have celebrity insurance
um
oh no i hear non-celebrity noises
and paparazzi no thanks no thanks
um
i'm a celebrity
i'm a celebrity and i'd like to get out
of here i
hear normal people around me
oh god please
jesus
oh chase please sir
please oh god imagine what activated
oh jesus
oh paparazzi i said no cameras i said no
cameras
i said no cameras
oh my god
i said no cameras
that was a good okay i'm gonna need to
talk to my
manager
that's unacceptable oh oh no paparazzi
get off get off
oh oh oh
down goes down
stay away from my children
you can photograph me but don't
photograph my children get away from me
i'm a celebrity
i have a bigger paycheck than you
oh i'm a ghost i'm i'm laughing
i'm balding when i'm laughing
i'm a celebrity
i'm a celebrity uh i'm innocent i'm a
celebrity he's not a celebrity arrest
him arrest him arrest him
oh my head is [ __ ] bleeding